>> Now let's take a little deeper look at what is contained inside of the data
array. Now, if you recall, each layer is actually a large two-dimensional grid
of tile data. It's listed here in the JSON file as a single integer array.
Effectively, this is what we call raster scan order, where each row is listed in
the file after the previous row, linearly. The value of each element in the data
array actually has significance in itself. First off, if you see a zero value
that effectively means that no tile has been placed in that x,y position inside
of this layer. Any non-zero value represents a tile index for a given atlas.
Now, this is where things start to get a little bit tricky. Now, if you recall,
this little element here, first GID, that exists for each atlas that's listed in
our tile sets array. Now, if a zero value in the data array for a layer, it
means that there is no tile there. That means that the first element to
represent that a tile does exist must start with one. Each atlas that exists
inside of the tiled file will have an increasing first GID. Now, tiled has its
own heuristics on what the first GID should be for each subsequent atlas that's
loaded. We won't get into that other than to say that you need to know what this
number is. So, what we see here is that if we have a value of 167 in this data
array, and the first GID of the atlas starts with 1, this effectively means that
167 is the first atlas, tile number 166. Now, this makes a little bit more sense
once you start getting 4 or 5 different atlas layers on there. Right now, it may
seem a little bit [unknown]. The larger issue that you have to run into is what
does 166 actually mean. Now, recall once again that the atlas that's being given
to us is in raster scan order as well. So, the value of 166 is actually the
raster index into the 2-dimensional array. With this set up, computing the
coordinates for the atlas simply involves mapping the tile size to the right
offset inside the atlas itself.